[Musique]
pour cette édition l'équipe d'mjr 974
s'est rendue au refuge de la SPA à
[Musique]
Sainte-Marie accompagné des conseillers
départementaux du CDJ nous allons rendre
visite à nos amis à quatre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
passes au programme des dons des
promenades et des caresses ayant pour
seul objectif apporter de la joie et du
[Musique]
bonheur pour l'occasion aujourd'hui
c'est Flavie la mini reporter de mjr974
qui est allé à la rencontre de nos
généreux donateurs n'est-ce pas Flavie
salut à tous et oui aujourd'hui nous
allons à la rencontre de nos amis les
animaux
et on se dirige vers les membres du CDJ
pour en savoir plus sur cette journée
mais d'abord j'aimerais savoir qu'est-ce
que c'est que le CDJ le Conseil
départemental des Jeunes est une
instance de jeunes de 4e et de 3e c'est
surtout des délégués de classe ou des
élèves qui sont qui sont pas délégués
mais qui sont motivés pour être dans
cette instance et ça a pour objectif
d'aider les jeunes à la prise de parole
en public à connaître à participer à la
démocratie participative à la vie de de
son collège et à mener en à mettre en
place des des conduites de projet
d'accord mais pourquoi vous êtes venu à
la SPA aujourd'hui laasa était une
action qui tenait beaucoup à cord à tous
les conseillers départementaux joenes de
Lille et cette cause nous a vraiment
sensibilisé et on tenait aussi à
apporter une contribution au travail que
fait déjà à merveille la SPA pour
commencer ça on a fait une réunion avec
la commission Nord et et on a décidé
qu'on devrait faire une action avec les
animaux contre la maltraitance des
animaux et leur abandon donc ce projet
était validé par toutes les commissions
parce que tous les jeunes pensaient
qu'il était important de soutenir les
animaux ok donc si j'ai bien compris le
CDJ est venu pour aider les bénévoles de
la SPA et accorder un peu de temps et
d'attention aux animaux c'est ça Yaz tu
as tout compris Flavie mais pourquoi
devenir memb du CDJ dès l'année de 4e
dès que le premier la première
rassemblée vu l'émotion qu'il y avait
comment tout le monde était était lié en
fait par le lien déjà Jessie elle est
super et tout le monde était lié par ce
lien du coup je me suis dit bah pourquoi
peut-être pas moi l'année
d'ensuite quelle est l'importance
d'organiser une telle journée avec ces
jeunes conseillers alors c'est une
journée qui est vraiment très très très
sympathique puisque c'est la deuxième
fois que nous accueillons ces jeunes du
conseil général et nous sommes très
heureux de voir que ces jeunes sont très
très très motivés concernant la cause
animals aujourd'hui grâce à eux ben les
gens les enfants ils ont été
sensibilisés ils ont vu bah comment on
élève les animaux comment il faut les
sentir comment qu'est-ce qu'il faut
donner à manger et surtout qu'est-ce
qu'il faut pas faire AC les animaux que
ce soit les taper ou les taper les jeter
dans le CH et tout que voulez-vous
défendre aujourd'hui euh les animaux ont
aussi le droit d'être traiter avec soin
et il y a tellement d'animaux maltraités
dans les rues et tout ça on se doit
aussi de faire quelque chose d'agir à
notre échelle bien sûr mais on se doit
de le faire quand même parce que bon
animaux c'est un me comme les autre fa
pas mal à à pas faire ce sont des êtres
vivants comme nous et qui méritentah
d'être bien
traité nous en tant que jeune c'est
important qu'on s'investisse parce que
on est la génération de demain et donc
pour finir les animaux ils ont avant
tout besoin ils ont besoin d'amour
beaucoup d'amour de l'amour surtout de
l'amour d'un chien l'amour c'est le plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
important
[Applaudissements]
foreign